y le quiero preguntar a nicolás a qué se
debe entonces que estos dos candidatos
ultra conservadores hayan obtenido un
buen respaldo en estos comicios
una evolución una evolución natural de
los últimos 20 años antich
anticapitalista antiglobalización pero
no
que genera una reacción identitaria eso
es algo que se ha visto en el mundo
entero
desde américa
de trampa hasta hasta los partidos los
partidos de extrema de extrema derecha
alemanes austríacos polacos que están
que están reconstruyendo están
consolidando
consolidando de verdad un respaldo
electoral importante en el mundo entero
estamos así creo que es el síntoma de la
desesperación que existe una ciencia
política de las primeras cosas que
aprendemos es que cuando ya no se confía
en el sistema cuando ya no se confía en
la clase en la clase dirigente los
extremos suben y podemos ver que si
reunimos los extremos en los otros dos
en estas elecciones pues llegamos a más
de 50% significa que realmente hay un
problema sistémico y este problema
sistémico se debe pues no se puede los
problemas que es de servicios o de los
extremos no resuelven los problemas
sistémicos republicanos pero son la
alternativa entonces lo que hay que
esperar es que es que de alguna manera
de melanoma com
reciba el mensaje
tengo muy poca esperanza de que lo haga
pero que realmente busque durante su
presidencia reunir más que dividir como
lo ha hecho entre los últimos cinco años
esto ya nos había dicho que no le gusta
jugar a la bola de cristal sin embargo
debo hacerle esta pregunta y es en medio
este cansancio del sistema y del
surgimiento de los extremos y de que hay
una probabilidad o usted considera que
más como puede no escuchar el mensaje
que podría pasar en segunda vuelta
en segunda vuelta lo que nos podría pues
lo que podría pasar es que el
desespero aunque existe una población
francesa por emanuel macro no pueda
generar que votación que no solamente
los ultraconservadores voten por
imágenes recordemos que la vez pasada
recibió el 21 por ciento de los votos
para la segunda vuelta llegó el 37 si no
estoy equivocado y es significa que el
16 por ciento de la población que no era
de extrema derecha en principio voto por
ella si se réplica si se repite este
este modelo en este momento se recupera
todos los votos centro o los votos de
protesta contra macro no hay una
probabilidad una posibilidad más que
probabilidad en la posibilidad de que de
que sea mucho más reñido de lo que se
podría esperar y que finalmente pues en
imágenes de no esté lejos de la victoria
lo que podemos esperar es que aunque
primero esperar que no pase eje y
segundo podemos esperar que después ella
no tenga la fuerza suficiente para
imponerse en las legislativas pero en
este momento estamos mucho más cercanos
de la victoria que nunca de una victoria
del extrema derecha en francés y nuestro
invitado nicolás murió hace ya